[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'adore j'adore mais qu'est ce que t'es
bête tu sens bon à bonn et bêtes us en
bourse sur la scène la mère restée bonne
série on ce qui fait alors non pas du
tout alors jessica vous êtes magnifique
en tout cas est toutes les deux la dans
un avion j'espère que rappaz de
dépressurisation parce que la craie
voilà battouta merci les cheveux merci
dsk ne vous inquiétez pas elle n'est pas
comme à la mer je me noie pas jessica
démarche est avec nous elle est
originaire de tarascon dans les bouches
du rhône avait actuellement près
d'avignon et vous avez fait les
marseille à rio les ch'tis contre les
marseillais les marseillais en thaïlande
les ch'tis et les marseillais la
revanche les marseillais sens africa les
marseillais les ch'tis le reste du monde
les marseillais encore on a fait comme
ça mais rica et l'aller marseille encore
en afrique du sud en fait fait que les
marseillais avec des destinations
vous êtes en couple avec nicolas comme
vous nous l'avez dit vous allez monter
un salon d'esthétique mais quoi venir et
7-6 6-3 sur arles merci et bat très bien
et selon le magazine public vous
gagneriez 24000 euros par mois en
placement de produit juste pour faire
des petits tweets comme ça russe
ouais voilà sinon je gagne de ma vie
après un bon repas voulais pas en parler
j'ai l'impression que j'en parle mais je
gagne bien ma vie après je vois pas
pourquoi il ya marion cotillard qui fait
des panneaux publicitaires elle prend de
l'argent je vois pourquoi moi je le
ferai pas si on doit parce qu'on ne
vient pas une artiste alors alors alors
là la laisse mes agents n'a rien à voir
elle a tout à fait le droit de le faire
aussi un ballon qu'il ya les électriques
n'en fait si si si si l'on regarde on
n'en fait pas nous a énormément fait
enora mathieu tout ça vaut bien les
doigts vous êtes tous le droit d'en
faire vous avez tout à fait raison mais
c'est vrai que si les marques la demande
et jessica elle a une aura aujourd'hui
chez les 15 24 ans qui est énorme
je peux vous dire aujourd'hui jessica
vous l'a lâché auprès de jeunes et vous
lâcher marion cotillard vous allez voir
je pense que mes ennuis au quotidien on
aime beaucoup qui a beaucoup de talent
peut faire sur marcher tranquille 1 mais
par rapport à 6,6 kg six classes et une
émeute info le savoir quand elle passe
dans les couloirs sur la tête de ma mère
je croyais que michael jackson était
[Rires]
très intelligent une autre fois et là
mais elles montrent un but est vraiment
non mais c'est assez rare pour les
candidates à épines et on va pas
sympathique
elle est très sympa confié le voir que
vous faites mais je le trouve sympathie
merci j'ai moi même